DON DODGE: Hello everyone.
I'm Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today my guest is Jason
Calacanis, my longtime friend,
and it's a bit of a change for
Jason because normally he's in
this chair, so I've turned
the tables on him today.
Welcome Jason.
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah, now
the interviewer is the
interviewee.
DON DODGE: That's right.
JASON CALACANIS: It's
actually quite nice.
I don't have the pressure of
having to come up with great
questions, you do.
DON DODGE: Well, yeah.
The pressure's on me today.
All right.
You've done a lot of things
in your life.
You've been an entrepreneur,
you're an angel investor,
you're a conference promoter,
you do it all.
So let me start with
a simple question.
Are entrepreneurs
born or made?
JASON CALACANIS: That is a
question for the ages.
I ask that question a lot when
I'm on my show and I get a
divergent set of responses.
In the response of they're made,
you can find life events
that seem to make people
entrepreneurial, like having a
parent who's an entrepreneur
is a pretty good indicator
that the person could become
entrepreneurial.
Actually, I find a lot of
times a dysfunctional
relationship with one of the
parents in a lot of the
entrepreneurs, like they had a
dad who was particularly hard
on them, or a mom who was
particularly hard on them and
they had something to prove.
I don't think that
they're born.
I think they get made by their
childhoods in a large way, and
then sometimes when they get out
into the real world, just
something happens in their
business career where they
experience some massive
frustration and they think,
the world should be better than
this, or I'm being held
back, some critical moment.
I had a father who was
entrepreneurial, and he was
very hard on me and very hard on
himself, just in running a
restaurant and a bar
in Brooklyn.
And that really set me up for an
incredibly hard work ethic
and to be very resilient and
dedicated to building companies.
But then also when I went into
the workforce, I just saw
people and I saw companies
that I worked at being
inefficient, and I always
reflected on the efficiency
and the diligence my dad put
into his businesses, the way
he cared, into what I
did as an employee.
And when you go to sometimes
work at a big company--
I mean, we don't see this in the
tech industry as much, but
in the rest of the world,
efficient people who really
want to change the world are not
appreciated in a big media
company, or a big consumer
goods company, or a Wall
Street firm, or a bank,
or a law firm.
In the technology industry,
we celebrate those people.
We want to get those rabble
rousers into the companies,
the people who are pushing
the envelope.
In fact, people look for
that in employees.
But in the rest of the world,
they're not appreciated.
And so I think a lot of the
entrepreneurs I meet are
functionally unemployable.
They basically run into bosses
and they say things to them
like, you need to learn how to
work within the system, you
need to wait in line, you
need to respect the
hierarchy above you.
When you start hearing things
like that in your career, it
means that you should probably
be an entrepreneur.
It means that you're probably
not really a great employee,
you're a great leader.
DON DODGE: So do you think
there's a difference between a
businessman and an
entrepreneur?
A businessman makes money, an
entrepreneur changes the world?
Is there something like that?
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah.
I mean, some people go to work
every day to put a roof over
their family's head and to put
food on the table, and there
is an honor and a respect
I have for
those people, obviously.
There's nothing more noble than
being able to take care
of and provide for
your family.
But you can even do that with
an entrepreneurial spirit.
And so Mark Pincus from Zynga
talks about everybody being
the CEO of something
in his company.
You could be in a big company
and still have that
entrepreneurial spirit where
you're thinking about how to
innovate, and how to change the
world, and put a dent in
it, and try to move the
human race forward.
And I think that's really what
entrepreneurship is is that
you're relentless in your
pursuit of making something
that didn't exist before, trying
to make the world a
little better, trying to make
the experience a little
better, looking at things and
saying, if that was 10% better
or 20% better or 200% better,
what would it look like?
And then trying to take that
vision and make it reality.
And the time between when you
see something visionary like
that and it becomes de rigueur
and people just look at it and
go, well, of course you can
check into any location and
have all your friends know where
you are, and you know
where all your friends are--
that took Foursquare a good
decade to figure out, and
those kind of solutions, it's a
lot of hard work in between
doing that.
And a lot of times people look
at that journey of, things
should be different this
way and I see the world
differently, I want things
to function the way
I think they should.
It's so hard to make that
actually happen that most
people never do the first
step, which is trying.
And that's 99% and 1%.
Everybody knows that things
should be better, everybody's
got ideas of how to make
things better.
Ideas are very easy, they're
a commodity.
There's really not much
value in ideas.
Really the person who says, I'm
going to take that idea
and really try to make it
actually manifest itself into
a product or service that people
can consume and engage
with and fall in love with,
that's entrepreneurship.
That's the difference.
DON DODGE: So what motivates
you as an entrepreneur?
JASON CALACANIS: That's
interesting.
It's been different things at
different points in my life.
I'm 41 now.
And when I was 22 or 23,
I had a lot to prove.
And I don't know exactly who I
was proving it to, in part
myself, in part my
dad, in part the
people I grew up with.
I wanted to prove that I could
do something more than just be
a cop or a bartender, which
was pretty much my career
path, was either a cop
or a bartender.
DON DODGE: Because your
father owned a bar--
JASON CALACANIS: And
he was a bartender.
DON DODGE: Your older
brother--
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah, my
younger brother became a cop
and then a fireman, and I have
great respect for what he
does, running into burning
buildings, a lot easier than
building websites.
But I wanted to try to
do something really
great with my life.
I just had this sense that I
wanted to be more than what
people expected of me.
I think early on, a lot of
entrepreneurs, it's like they
have something to
prove like that.
And then I incorporated
a lot of
competitiveness into what I did.
I wanted to be better than the
other person doing it.
And then I had to start making
up sort of goals for myself,
like I wanted to beat
people by 2x.
It was like OK, Engadget became
bigger than Gizmodo
when I was building the blog
companies, and when I was 30
years old, 35 years old, I was
just like, I want to have
three times the traffic
of them.
I don't want to just beat them,
I want to dominate them.
You have these immature
motivations, I think, and
competitive motivations, and
then at a certain point when
you've accomplished something,
when I first sold Weblogs, Inc
and I was able to financially
not have to work again, and
had achieved some level of
success and pride in what I
had done, I had to take a deep
look in the mirror and say
this exact question,
what motivates me?
And you have this big moment
like OK, I've made it to the
top of the hill.
What now?
And then you realize, you're
a mountain climber.
You just love climbing
mountains.
You're not trying to get to the
top of the hill, you're
just trying to climb.
That's what I am.
I'm just a climber.
I like to climb.
I love being at the base camp
and seeing people who've never
climbed a mountain saying,
I want to climb,
it's my first time.
Can you help me?
For me, that's angel
investing.
For me, that's the LAUNCH
conference.
I love seeing them go up the
cliff and all the excitement
of getting up to the
top and succeeding.
And for myself personally, I
just love to build things, and
I love building teams, and I
love being involved with
people who are building teams.
It's a rush for me.
I mean that, to me, is
my greatest rush.
The act of creation, the act
of people getting off the
bench and then saying, I'm going
to make that dent in the
universe, I'm going to try to
innovate, I'm going to try to
take this vision I have
and make it reality.
And that's the motivation
for me today, I think.
In what I'll call the second
half of my career, I get as
much enjoyment out of, and
probably more, helping other
people succeed, making other
entrepreneurs, making people
entrepreneurial, helping them
grow their visions.
The best six weeks of the year
for me, putting my family
aside and personal life and
taking kids on vacation, which
is a whole level of joy
that transcends all
entrepreneurship, but the four
weeks, six weeks before the
LAUNCH conference and prior
to that, the TechCrunch50
Conference, where I coached
the companies.
I helped always select the
companies, but I was always
the person who brought them
and coached them.
And watching them give their
presentation three, four, five
times and go from a five or six
to a nine or a ten, that
to me was just like,
I love that.
And I watched Dropbox launch and
Drew just gave a terrible
presentation the first time,
it crashed, it was just a
disaster with Dropbox.
And then watching Mint, and
Fitbit, and Yammer, and
Redbeacon, all these great
companies, and now Space
Monkey, and Alltuition and the
latest crop of companies.
Watching them succeed through
that process and then going on
stage and the world seeing them
and the world seeing what
I've seen for four or five weeks
in the laboratory, and
they're just as excited about
as I am, I mean, there are
hugs and tears and emotions
running very deep backstage
that people don't see between
myself, the other people who
produce the event, the judges.
It's as close to a spiritual,
Zen moment as I have in my
professional career is those
moments after people get off
stage and I just tell them, you
did it, it was amazing.
And they say, I couldn't have
done it without you.
I live for that.
I live for it.
DON DODGE: It's almost
like being present at
the birth of a child.
JASON CALACANIS: It
is in a way, yes.
DON DODGE: It's an amazing
experience.
JASON CALACANIS: Having
experienced the birth of a
child, it is, yes.
It is exactly like that
experience of overwhelming joy
that something new is in your
life and you know life will
never be the same.
DON DODGE: And you had a part
in making it happen.
JASON CALACANIS: And you had
some part in making it happen.
In the case of my beautiful
daughter, I
think I had about 0.1%.
I think my wive did
about 99.9%.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
So when did you know that you
wanted to be an entrepreneur?
JASON CALACANIS: At a
very young age, 12,
13, 14 years old.
DON DODGE: And when did you
start your first company?
JASON CALACANIS: Well, putting
aside working for my dad,
which was kind of
entrepreneurial being in his
startup, my first business was
my dad had somebody who owed
him money from a poker game
and backgammon, and this
person had gotten into
my father for a
decent amount of cash.
Right now, you're probably
wondering, wow, where is this
story going?
And the guy was kind
of connected in a
Brooklyn kind of way.
DON DODGE: Uh oh.
JASON CALACANIS: And the
guy said, listen, John.
I'm going to get you that money
I owe you from the poker
game and from the backgammon.
But to hold you over, I
know your son loves
the Star Wars films.
Here's a copy of The Empire
Strikes Back.
And he handed him a VHS tape
with The Empire Strikes Back.
Now, The Empire Strikes Back had
been in movie theaters a
year earlier, and Star Wars was
not out on VHS, and my dad
had a VHS player, which in 1984
or '85 was just crazy.
And I was in junior high school,
it was '83, '84,
something like that.
And my dad came home, and he
said, hey, you know The Empire
Strikes Back?
I was like yeah, we
saw it five times.
He was like, here you go.
How did you get this?
Oh, you know, a guy
owed me a thing.
The guy had obviously put a
camera up and taped The Empire
Strikes Back at a theater in
Bensonhurst, Brooklyn, and I
had a copy of the film.
So then I charged my friends to
come over to the house, $1
each, to watch the film.
And then they said, can
I get a copy of it?
And I said, well, I don't
know how to make a copy.
And they said, oh, OK.
And so then I started figuring
out how to put two VHS tapes
together, got my friend to give
me his VHS player, and
made copies of the tape, and
then I started selling illegal
bootleg copies of The
Empire Strikes Back.
I think the statute of
limitation's over.
But I literally was selling at
school for $35, I came up with
a price of $35, copies of
Empire Strikes Back.
I had a line out the door.
I'd literally sold 20 or
30 copies of them.
DON DODGE: And that's when you
knew you wanted to be an
entrepreneur.
JASON CALACANIS: I said, wow,
I'm printing money.
I had no concept
of intellectual
property at the time.
I just knew that it would take
me two hours to make a copy
because you had to do
it in real time.
You would put one tape in, you
would have the audio, video go
out into another VHS,
and you'd literally
record it in real time.
It wasn't a drag
and drop copy.
So it took me two hours to make
a copy, and if anything
got screwed up in the middle,
I had to start
over, and that happened.
So it was like, oh wow, in
two hours, I made $35.
I'm making $20 an hour or
whatever, $17 an hour.
It was an incredible
revelation to me.
That was my first business.
And then after that, I started
programming databases.
I just had an IBM PC Junior in
1982 or '83 at the same time
and just got into computers,
and learned how to use
databases and Lotus 1-2-3, and
started doing consulting work
for $10 an hour, $15 an hour
teaching people how to use
software and working in little
mom and pop offices, like a
lot of people did.
DON DODGE: So Silicon
Alley Reporter.
That was your first
company, right?
JASON CALACANIS: That was my
first big company, yeah.
I just basically started a
magazine about the internet in
1995 and it was a photocopy.
I put about $4,000 on my credit
cards to print it, and
it was a pretty scary moment
because I had done all the
Pagemaker, which was the
original sort of Quark Express
desktop publishing software,
and I made the magazine.
I called it a magazine, it
was really tabloid paper
photocopied, folded in half,
and I found a place in
Manhattan, Village Printers up
on 45th Street and a guy named
Jose, if he still works there,
thank you, folded in half and
put a staple in the middle.
And so I said, how much is it?
He said, it's like
$0.05 a copy.
I said, great, 16
pages, whatever.
It's eight pages and $0.40 a
copy or whatever, and I'll
take this many copies.
So I go up there and I go to
pick them up, and he goes OK,
it's $4,000.
I said, wait a minute, it's
$2,000, [INAUDIBLE].
He goes, yeah, but
it's two-sided.
It's $0.05 a side to
make a photocopy.
I said, you didn't say that.
You said $0.05 a thing.
He said, no, no, I
said both sides.
I said, I can't afford that.
He said, all right, I'll split
the difference with you.
But I put the money on my credit
cards, and then that
magazine, obviously
you guys know the
history of the internet.
The internet exploded during
that time and I started
hosting conferences, and they
started getting bigger and
bigger, and remember back in
1999 or 2000 or something, a
PR person had called me from
some bizarrely named company
in the valley and said, we want
to have this guy Sergey
give a keynote at your
conference in New York.
I said, what's the name
of the company?
They said Google, and I said,
yeah, I heard about it.
You guys are the ones who
provide the search software
for Yahoo, right?
And they said, yeah.
I said, yeah, I don't think that
you guys are big enough
to be a fireside chat.
I'll put Sergey on a panel.
And the PR person was
like, listen, he's
really a smart guy.
You really should give
him a fireside chat.
And I said, all right, fine.
I did a fireside chat with
Sergey Brin in 2000 or
whatever, right before the
bubble burst, and it was
great, it was before
they were public.
And I still know Sergey to this
day, and he's a great
guy, a very smart guy.
But that magazine basically
gave me the ability to sit
with entrepreneurs and
say, where do you
think the world's going?
And then I was a journalist
and I wrote about it.
And journalism is really this
incredible fast track to
becoming an entrepreneur,
because you get to talk to a
dozen people a week who tell
you which direction the
world's going, and boy, founders
and CEOs will tell
you everything.
And when they tell you
everything, it's almost like
you get this sort of incredible
view of the
landscape from 20 different
people's perspective.
Fred Wilson of Union Square
Ventures was doing
Flatiron at the time.
His wife Joanne worked for me at
Silicon Alley Reporter and
sold the ads.
So Fred was a VC who would be
telling me about all these
great companies we were seeing
and introducing people to me,
I would meet people and send
them to Fred, who was a VC,
and then I was just really in
this middle of the zeitgeist.
And I also realized the power of
media and conferences, and
the person who puts the person
on the cover of the magazine,
or throws the event, or pays for
the check at dinner gets a
disproportionate amount of
credit for everything that
occurs in that magazine, at
that event, or at dinner.
And that's why I've always loved
to host events and host
things, because it's just a
way for me to get to meet
everybody, and anything that
occurs at that event, people
just attribute to you.
Wow, Jason helped me because I
met my wife at this event or I
met my investor at this event.
I get those stories all the
time, and I'm like, really?
I didn't even know you were at
that event, but that's awesome
that it impacted your life.
I'm a very social guy.
I loved being a magazine
editor.
It was the time of my life, and
we grew it to 70 people
and $11.6 million a
year in revenue.
DON DODGE: So you've done
Silicon Alley Reporter and
Weblogs, Inc, and Mahalo, and
Open Angel Forum, and
TechCrunch50.
JASON CALACANIS: I love
creating brands.
DON DODGE: LAUNCH, you're a
writer in your own right.
Is there any separation, or
is that all just Jason?
It's all one thing?
JASON CALACANIS: I think
that's all Jason.
I used to fret over it a
little bit, and then I
realized, I have a little
entrepreneurial ADD, I get
excited, I have enthusiasm, but
I'm not going to try to
bridle it and put it all
into one project.
If I want to do an event, and
I want to write my email
newsletter, and I want to host
This Week In Startups, and I
want to be the CEO of Mahalo
and pursue education and do
apps and all this stuff, I'm
going to do everything.
And I look at one of the great
entrepreneurs of our time, not
Steve Jobs, Jay-Z, and he is
an amazing entrepreneur.
He is an artist who's onstage,
and he is probably the
greatest rapper alive today,
in my opinion, he is, and
Biggie Smalls was probably
the best that ever
lived, rest in peace.
But Jay-Z also ran a record
label, and manages other
people's careers and
a clothing line,
and this other stuff.
And I just think those rap
artists and people in the hip
hop space have a very good view
of the world, which is
why not try everything?
Why not do a little
bit of everything?
And if some people think you're
doing too much, that's
on them, that's not on me.
People say oh, well, what do
your investors in this company
think about you working
on this?
They love the fact
that I'm diverse.
They love the fact that I get to
spend a couple of weeks in
the LAUNCH Conference, learn a
lot, and then parlay that into
my own day-to-day experience as
an entrepreneur, and I just
love being involved in a lot
of different things.
So I don't fret over it
too much anymore.
Although I will say, ever since
having a child, I am
getting a little tired.
DON DODGE: How do you
measure success?
JASON CALACANIS: That's a
great, great question.
There's ways I measure success
in other people, right?
You can look at somebody's
exit, that's a
very tangible number.
Mark Gibbons sold his company
for this many billions of
dollars, and what's the
valuation of that company?
That's a very literal thing.
But for me, success is, how much
joy are you getting out
of what you're doing
every day?
How much excitement and
enthusiasm do you have for
that project and for the
people you work with?
And how much do you love coming
to work every day and
building stuff?
And to me, that's really success
as an entrepreneur.
And I have my own little
quirk, and it's just a
personal thing, but I like to
create brands that last the
test of time.
Even if they're not functioning
anymore, like
Silicon Alley Reporter doesn't
exist, but that people hold
that special place in their
heart for them, that they
impacted somebody deeply.
So even though TechCrunch50
doesn't exist on its own
anymore, it exists as Mike's
version in TechCrunch
disrupting my version in LAUNCH,
those three years of
TechCrunch50 were three of the
best years of conference
production ever done, the best
companies, and Mike and I had
a great collaboration there.
Sure, there was tension.
You put two huge elephants in a
room, something is going to
get knocked over, somebody's
going to get stepped
on sooner or later.
But 10 years from now, 20 years
from now, we'll look
back on those years together as
some of the best years of
conference production ever done,
and the people who came
out of those three years feel
that those were a very
important brand to them.
People feel that way about
Engadget, people feel that way
about Joystick and Autoblog,
they feel
that way about LAUNCH.
Open Angel Forum I don't really
do any more in some of
the major cities because they
don't need it, right?
Angel List is sort of a more
powerful version of Open Angel
Forum, and angel rounds are
closing so quickly you don't
really need an Open Angel
Forum anymore.
That was the reason I stopped
doing it was because every
time I would sign up five
companies for Open Angel
Forum, they would tell me a
week before the event that
they filled their round and that
they couldn't present.
I said, OK fine.
Then I'm only left with the
companies that are bad, I
don't want to put on companies
or the weaker companies.
But people still say, oh, at
Open Angel Forum, I invested
in Reportive, or I
met Backupify.
So for me, that's my own little
personal quirk is, how
much did the brand
mean to people?
How well-crafted was
the product?
And I got that from my dad,
because he used to really take
pride and he used to say,
what's on the plate?
What's on the plate?
He said, that's where it occurs,
that's the experience.
What do you put on the plate?
DON DODGE: Was that a
restaurant metaphor?
JASON CALACANIS: It was
a restaurant metaphor.
He said it doesn't matter.
The waiter could be the worst
waiter in the world, it might
not be the fanciest designed
room, but if what's on the
plate is absolutely delicious
and awesome, people will
forgive it.
When I was young, I was like, I
don't know about that, Pop.
The room matters, and the waiter
matters, and sure, all
those details matter, but I
understand philosophically
what he was getting at, which
was the product at its core
transcends everything
around it.
So in the example of the LAUNCH
Conference, the space
is a big, cavernous warehouse
that's not perfect, and the
sound's not always perfect
because it's so cavernous, and
the temperature might not be
easy to regulate, and maybe
the food's not perfect all the
time, but what's on the
plate-- and in the case
of a conference, it's
what's on the stage--
is perfect.
And I know it's perfect because
I sit there in the
laboratory for six weeks, four
weeks, fretting over each
presentation and going over it
five or six times, and then
Tyler does it a couple
times and Karen
does it a couple times.
I know what's on the plate is
going to be good, and that's
just where I focus my energy.
And I think that's actually
where the world's going, and I
just wrote about this in an
email called "The Age of
Excellence." I think the
world has no more
place for good products.
I think the concept of
"good" is going away.
Good is the same as average
is the same as
bad in people's minds.
Anything that's just
good, average--
because there's excellence,
and it's so clear when
something's excellent, people
are just drawn to it.
And I think this was the problem
I had in search, which
was Google search results,
people can pick them apart on
the edges, but they're
excellent and
they get the job done.
And then when I created a search
engine to compete with
it, it was sometimes a
little bit better,
sometimes a little worse.
It's very hard to compete with
something that's excellent,
and people will not leave
something that's excellent for
another excellent thing,
or certainly not for
another good thing.
And that's where competition
becomes so hard against
incumbents who have
a great product.
And you see that with Apple,
you see it with Google with
search, you see it
with the iPhone.
It's very difficult
to compete against
excellent, excellent products.
It's got profound ramifications,
I think, for
the world and for employment
and for founders that
excellence is table stakes.
Excellence is the baseline.
It means if you can't create
that amazing, excellent
product and it comes out
average, you're better off
just turning it off and
then trying again to
make something excellent.
And that wasn't the case just
five, 10, 15 years ago.
Things like distribution, a
celebrity affiliation, some
patented business technique,
some marketing technique, all
these other things could
have mattered.
But now we're going to a world
where what's on the plate is
all that matters.
The product wins.
If an app has a histogram with
five stars, four stars, and
then very little three, two,
and ones, whether it's on
Yelp, Amazon, or iTunes, people
buy it instantly.
When the histogram becomes even,
people generally don't
buy it, or they question it, and
when the histogram becomes
upside down, when it looks like
an upside down pistol and
there's only one or two four-
or five-star reviews and
there's a lot of one- and
two-star reviews, people will
absolutely not buy it, and
that's going to happen in
every category.
Right now, we see it in
products, we see it in
restaurants, we see it in apps,
but it's going to go to
television shows and movies.
And people are not going to go
see Transformers Four or Five
if it really sucks, because
they're going to know the
histogram and the transparency
will be there, and they're
going to go find something on
Kickstarter, and they're going
to go spend their money on
something that's of quality.
You see it on television
to a certain extent.
People don't just turn on ABC,
NBC, and CBS and watch what's
on there anymore.
They seek out what's
on HBO, what's on
Showtime, what's on AMC.
The most loved shows are
not on network anymore.
Mad Men, Boardwalk Empire,
Walking Dead, The Wire, The
Shield, Damages, all these shows
that people fall in love
with and have high net promoter
scores and that
people are passionate about are
not on network television.
DON DODGE: Well, that's because
the competitive
landscape has changed.
So today, it's easy to
start a company but
hard to build a business.
JASON CALACANIS: Starting is
easy, finishing is hard.
DON DODGE: Do you think that's
because it's so easy to start
a company now, it's so cheap
to start a company, that
everyone is doing it?
And it's very, very hard to
stand up above the crowd and
be noticed and be that excellent
product that
everyone wants to buy.
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah.
That's exactly what's happening,
and I think you can
attribute it to two factors.
One we'll call the open
source movement.
When you started building
internet companies, you had to
go to Oracle and give them this
huge big dump truck of
money to start your company.
Here, Oracle, here's $250,000
for a license.
Now it's like, oh, I'm using
MySQL and I'm using Hadoop, or
I'm using this HBase,
or whatever,
I'm not paying anybody.
And oh, you had to buy all these
servers from Sun, and
now it's like, I'm buying
commodity hardware
or I'm in the cloud.
I'm on EC2, I'm on Rackspace's
cloud, and I'm just paying a
couple hundred bucks
for hosting.
So all that cost has gone down
to what's essentially zero,
minimal cost.
And then you have the Zuckerberg
effect, which
follows the Jobs, Larry, Sergey,
Bill Gates effects of
the past, which is the heroes
of our society are moving
towards entrepreneurship, people
who create beautiful
things that impact
people's lives.
And it used to be our heroes
were celebrities, it used to
be our heroes maybe were
politicians in some cases, or
musicians, rock stars,
TV stars.
And in those cases, maybe they
have artistic moments of
greatness, but when the movie
The Social Network came out, I
think that's a pretty clear
starting pistol that young
people aspire to create
Facebook, not a CD or a movie.
They want to create
the next Facebook.
And you have two sons.
What do they want to do?
They want to start
companies, right?
DON DODGE: Right.
JASON CALACANIS: And I think
every parent is facing that.
So now, can all companies
be successful?
Of course not.
But I don't complain about that
because if the cost of
launching a company is zero or
close to it and somebody gets
an angel round for $25,000 or
$250,000 or $500,000 and it
doesn't work out, the cost is
very low to society, to the
investors, to the
entrepreneur.
They can always go to work
at a bigger company.
So you do have issues like
there's too many entrepreneurs
out there, and there's too many
people who are B or C
level players trying to be the
CEO when really they're a
great VP of product, or they're
a great business
development leader, or they're a
great operations person, and
they're taking the CEO slot,
and it would be better for
three or four of those companies
to consolidate and
really make a run at a
meaningful business.
But that's OK.
I don't think there's any
downside, and people, oh my
god, Y Combinator or
TechStars, most
companies will fail.
If you look at Y Combinator or
TechStars as an alternative to
college, getting paid $15,000
or $25,000 to go build a
product for six months, you're
going to learn a heck of a lot
more than being $150,000
or $250,000 in
debt to the Ivy League.
If Harvard was such a great,
amazing program itself, why
aren't there 100 Harvard?
Why isn't there a Harvard
in every city that takes
everybody from IQ of 100
to an IQ of 120?
Well, it's because that program
is not so great.
Harvard is great because they
have a great selection program
and it's got a great history,
and it's got a great logo, and
it's all charismatic
and a great legacy.
But the fact is, that's not
a great product for making
people hyper-intelligent.
It's a great place for
hyper-intelligent people to
spend four years, and then come
out as intelligent as
they were, and perhaps a
little more socialized.
So the way I look at it is, you
go into TechStars, you go
into Y Combinator, you go into
even the funded, any of these
places, and you come
out much better.
And that's back to your original
question about, can
you learn entrepreneurship
or not?
And the truth is, you can.
You can learn it.
Now, can you learn passion,
can you learn leadership?
Yeah, you can learn those
things, but there's certain
cases, with passion you have it
or you don't or whatever,
desire, hunger.
Who knows, that's a harder
question to answer.
But when it comes to
entrepreneurship, yeah, you
can learn a lot.
And you can certainly a lot of
the blocking and tackling of
starting a company.
In my day, starting a
company was hard.
I sound like an old man at 41,
but 10 years ago, nobody knew
what a term sheet looked
like until you got one.
Now, you just type in
"term sheet," you
see 100 term sheets.
You ask any entrepreneur
for a term sheet,
they'll give it to you.
People don't know what financing
documents look like,
now you can get them for free.
Wilson Sonsini puts out
free documents.
Here's all the documents,
take a look at them.
It's amazing how much
easier it is.
And all that hardship, we like
to look back on it as
entrepreneurs, oh, we had to go
through and suffer through
all that stuff so it
made us stronger.
Maybe it did, maybe it didn't.
It was a waste of time.
We could have spent that time
on product, we would've made
better products.
So I don't have this bias about
it, but boy, what a
wonderful time we live in.
People can take risk now.
If you think about it like space
exploration, it's like
each of these start-ups, each
of these entrepreneurs is
sending a little probe into
the universe to see if the
planet is inhabitable.
Who cares if most of them
don't come back?
It doesn't matter.
All that matters is that some
come back with signs of life,
or water, or something of
value on that planet.
That's the beauty of this.
I don't buy this we're finding
too many start-ups things.
Yeah, the valuations are a
little out of whack, yeah some
people who are B players are
getting funded, or C players,
and they shouldn't.
Whatever, who cares?
What's the downside compared
to the upside?
What if we find life
on those planets?
What if we find the next Google,
what if we find the
next Apple, what if we find the
next Facebook, what if we
find the next Airbnb, Dropbox,
Fitbit, Room 77, Space Monkey?
Let's find those
opportunities.
DON DODGE: Absolutely.
You've had a lot of success in
your career, you've started
successful companies, but it's
not always that way.
JASON CALACANIS: Nope.
DON DODGE: Let's talk
about pivots and
about changing direction.
How do you know when it's time
to pivot versus when it's time
to persevere and push ahead?
JASON CALACANIS: That's a
timeless question, and it's
very relevant.
There's no exact way to
know, I'll be honest.
There are people who I
feel have given up on
problems and pivoted.
You see it all the time where
people try to make a consumer
product and they say, you know
what, we're just going to sell
a white label version of it.
And sometimes my heart breaks
because I'm like, how many
versions did you do?
Did you do one version
or two and gave up?
Did you talk to those
customers?
Did they tell you why they're
not using it?
Did you figure out why
they're not engaging?
If you look at something as
simple as web-based video,
video on the web sounds crazy
right now since web video is
such a big market.
People didn't believe that would
work 10 years ago, and
it took YouTube basically
picking up where iClips and
iFilm had left off.
Those companies had given up,
they had sold, and iFilm had
gone into servicing people,
servicing their video needs,
and real networks, and a lot
of people had tried to make
video work.
And then YouTube said,
OK, people have
done 80% of the work.
Let's do the last 20%.
A large portion of YouTube's
success was the fact that
Flash had finally worked
for video really well.
And nobody really had picked up
on that, and then Chad and
Steven, you had to give them a
lot of credit for realizing
that wait a second, video can
work without a plug-in?
Video could work seamlessly and
you could make it free?
I mean, one of the reasons why
video didn't take off was
because people were so concerned
about the bandwidth
cost that it required a credit
card to put a video online.
And really, the innovation of
YouTube was you didn't need a
credit card to put your
video online.
It seems so obvious today, and
you didn't need a plug-in.
It seems so obvious today.
So I think persevering
is very good.
Now, if you absolutely are
certain that you've explored
every option and that there's no
way to make it work, yeah,
then pivot.
I thought human-powered search
would work, and I really spent
two years, three years
of my career.
We had moderate success, and a
lot of the innovation we had
in search you see in products
like Google and Bing today.
Human is being put into Google
search results today with the
advent of Google+ and seeing
your friend's name, so it's
human, it's social.
It's the same as human, it's
just done a different way.
So in some way, I guess I get a
small victory by seeing that
happen, right?
But you can't make everything
work as an entrepreneur,
that's unrealistic.
And if everything you do in
your career is a home run,
that means you're not swinging
hard enough.
You're not swinging
for the fences.
You cannot win every time.
Two out of three things
you do should fail.
If you're not, if you're
succeeding at everything, that
means you set the benchmark
too low.
I knew was time to pivot when
Google's results started going
from 10 blue links to 10 blue
links with some content at the
top, and a YouTube video,
and some news.
And all of a sudden I was like
wow, that sort of was our
vision, and it's sort
of there already.
OK, no problem.
We'll just do something else.
And you look at what
work you've done.
I think the best pivots come
out of what lesson did you
learn from your failure?
What lessons did you learn from
your moderate success?
And I have to say, moderate
success is
much worse than failure.
DON DODGE: It's like
the walking dead.
JASON CALACANIS: That's
the kryptonite.
If you have moderate success,
if you can get your business
to exactly the amount of money
your payroll is and your burn
is, and you just go sideways,
that's when you're truly
screwed because you're
going to take your
eyes off the prize.
You'll be like, well, I'm sort
of making it, and then the
business goes like this.
That's bad.
DON DODGE: Let's talk
about passion.
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah.
DON DODGE: Passion is an
important ingredient to any
start-up, any business success,
and your point about
if you're at that sort of break
even point and kind of
doing OK, it's easy to lose
the passion then.
JASON CALACANIS: Yeah.
You're operating a business,
you're a mom and pop business.
Nothing wrong with that, but
some people could have passion
for running a small cafe, and
people are very satisfied with
the mochas, and you can bring
passion to that and I wouldn't
degrade the people
who are running
the mom and pop business.
But hey, the game we're in is
to build really impactful
products that change the world,
and to do that, you
need to bring a level of
passion because it's so
difficult and the passion is
what's going to get you
through the difficult times.
You will get your butt kicked
over and over and over again
if you're going after
something big.
And you don't have the passion,
when you get knocked
out, you're not going
to get up.
And man, I can tell you, the
best success of my career has
always come right after I've
gotten my butt kicked.
Right after I've gotten knocked
down and I've got that
blood in my mouth, and I can
taste my own blood in my
mouth, like, oh god, this is so
hard, I don't know if I can
do it anymore.
And you just pick yourself up
knowing you might get knocked
right back down, but you get up
and say, I'm going to try
again, that's when the
success happens.
And entrepreneurship
is a test of wills.
Who can fight through the
most pain and suffering?
Who can fight through the most
problems, the most headaches,
the most uncomfortable
conversations, the hardest
problems to solve, the problems
where you bring five
smart people into a room and
nobody can figure out the
solution, and three people feel
one way and two people
feel another way, and the next
day it flips, and there's no
clear answer.
That's when you know you're
on the verge of greatness,
because most people when they
get into those incredibly
difficult situations, they
capitulate and they give up
and they throw in the towel,
and for good reason because
it's hard and it's painful, and
there's more painful and
hard times in entrepreneurship
than there are good times.
It's just the nature of it.
And if it was easy, everybody
would do it.
And instead of 99% of people
going to work every day and 1%
going to be entrepreneurs,
it would be flipped.
It's not easy.
That's why most people
don't do it.
So if you choose to do it,
know that in those hard
moments when you're getting
your butt kicked and when
things look the most dark,
that the darkest hour is
before the dawn.
DON DODGE: Jason, you're one of
the most passionate people
that I know.
Thanks for being with us
today and sharing your
passion with us.
JASON CALACANIS: My pleasure.
DON DODGE: Thank you.
JASON CALACANIS: Just do it.